[Music]
well folks we are headed into halftime
on an absolute blowout Hill I can't help
but wonder if the league mandated
sensitivity training hasn't taken away
their edge now it seems a bad basketball
before but I don't even recognize the
team that's in front of me right now god
damn that someone are really screwed
y'all look some of us family seminar
very enlightening oh yeah you
enlightened all right as in they lighten
your ass up on the court what the hell
is wrong with you guys well for one
thing when you keep asking us what's
wrong with you guys it feels like you're
imposing a gender on us and some players
might have a hard time focusing in the
face of a constant micro aggression I'd
love to see a little aggression cuz
right now everybody's out there playing
like a bunch of bitches coach the word
bitches is so offensive I don't even
know where to begin what the are
you talking about the word bitches is
misogynistic it's like you're saying
we're playing like women implying that
women aren't as good at basketball
that's exactly what I'm saying
that's sexist and also not true when you
compare the fundamentals of the NBA and
the WNBA players personally I model my
game after Sheryl Swoopes I've always
thought of myself as more of a Diana
Taurasi latina Charles right now hey
knock knock hi how you doing coach I was
running some numbers and Darren over
there turns out that he's much more
effective as a power forward instead of
a center in the the first half boy if
you'll get your money ball home-schooled
Dexter's Laboratory looking ass out of
my locker room what is this what did you
just give my players that is something I
call vsauce3 it's something I'm working
on that helps enhance mid-game
performance it's chock full of
electrolytes and you put it on
vegetables coach it's just to preserve
our energy yes it's my special sauce no
you don't come into a room full of men
and start offering your special sauce
get your ass out of here sir Wow now
you're being homophobic I'm not
homophobic that sounded suspect
anyway remember what got us here ball
control ball control when they come to
the middle I want y'all to hit them with
hard deep what the hell are y'all
looking at
that was wasteful sure the city of Flint
would have liked that water oh you know
what I would love I would love dare to
goddamn box somebody out and grab a
rebound the way you play it we stand
about as much chance as a one-legged man
in the ass-kicking contest ablest it
Robert you closed out all your man you
out there moving like somebody's
granddaddy ages Terrance you out there
playing like a poor man's James Harden
closest I can't believe this the I
got to deal with in the finals it's
already bad enough my best play as a
white boy actually coach I identify as a
black man nigga what come on guys it's
our struggle haven't we been through
enough
[Music]